at what point was the roaches when was
the roaches and the sweaty and the skin
like falling off like because it was so
soggy alright I spend an extremely long
time fighting my case I got the lawyer
that the New Mexican Mafia guys
recommended to me hmm and because I
wasn't cooperating because I wouldn't
sign a plea bargain
the prosecutor pulled out every dirty
trick in the book including
criminalizing my girlfriend so she
couldn't visit me so as it's going along
I'm also in court when we go call all my
co-defendants I get to meet them so me
and wild man you know will I all right
we've got a united front now my lawyer
is the lead lawyer
nobody needs to cooperate don't sign
this think I'll exhibit a they were
giving everyone saying you work for
Shawn outward in the outward enterprise
and it was really pissing the prosecutor
off because in summing the Bulls case I
think 57 people arrested with him and
they all cooperated quite quickly
now our ID built like a tight crime
family kind of thing not a Matthieu
crime family a rave crime family now
we're talking cuddle puddles and Vicks
inhalers no Joe Pesci style you know
killing people in the boots of cars like
that right but we were all very
tight-knit family of misfits that had
come together in this community so only
four people cooperated in my entire case
which was phenomenal Wow so the process
the prosecutor was frantic Mylo saying
they've got a flimsy case they missed
the boat they don't have any drug
evidence against you it's just the
testimony these people uncle speaks on
my behalf he's ex-cop thinking wow this
is going great prosecutor she sabotages
the hearing the judge doubles my bond to
1.5 million dollars cash only now when
your bond goes over a mil you
automatically reclassified from medium
security of it's a maximum security
which was mostly murderers and I ended
up in a cellmate with a crystal
chemist so go over to max two in the
morning I've been in like prison
transportation all day yeah and sitting
in holding cells and whatnot pretty
tired and I get to the cell in the
Madison Street jail walk in it's a two
month cell and I see my cell mate asleep
on the top bunk at the back I'm thinking
that's Pitt we had one the way he's not
on the bottom bunk because where I come
from people fight over the bottom bunk
so I was thinking so he's not quite
right walking a little bit more
something drops off the ceiling and
bounces up in the shoulder like what was
that and I'm looking around at the walls
and the ceiling I can see this strange
movement like a swirl effect I think my
eyes are playing tricks I'm tripping so
I put my face right up to the wall to
see what was going on
and it was absolutely covered in
American cockroaches about the size of
an almond nut and they were just coming
out of holes in the wall the bunk where
I was supposed to sleep out there was
like these brackets attached to the wall
and they were just pouring out inches
away from the bunk and I don't thinking
you know I've got use of the violence by
now but how am I gonna deal with this
how am I gonna get to sleep so I'm
noticing my cellmate he's got like this
cocoon around him
this is this white sheet and a breathing
hole so he looks like The Mummy
so I got on the bunk I wrap myself up in
the sheet but this is a Sonoran desert
it's almost like 120 hundred thirty
degrees on your scale almost fifty
degrees on our scale and if you wrap
yourself up in a sheet it traps that hot
earth of your body
and you've already got all these
bleeding and itching skin infections and
bed sores because it's hardly any air
coming into the cells like a swamp
cooler but the only time it works on the
county health inspector what for to
build him so you saw itchy and you ski
so soggy though from sweating scratch
yourself clumps of your own skin comes
up on the nail so you compressed in this
this sheet around you and all the sweat
just driving you insane and in the end
you like your throw this [ __ ] up just
let them crawl on you now fortunately
they don't bite they start out tickling
your feet your limbs so this day if
anyone tickles my hands I flinch because
I woke up something like some tickling
my hands get on your face mouth nose but
the favorite place of all is going in
your ears see or ear wax it's like honey
to them I mean yeah I would rip a piece
of towel and make a little cloth to wash
my face and subset big in my ears and
get the earwax out and I put it
somewhere to dry and the cockroaches
would get on the flannel and they'd be
like pulsing on the earwax just sucking
the air wax up so that was the special
treat now this was constant 8:00 at
night was locked down all the prisoners
go back to the cells
guards lock the doors
you shut in the ten lights out just
before the lights go out
the cockroaches line up in the cracks in
the wall doing this movement birthday
antennae sticking out like an army
waiting to invade then as soon as the
lights go out that's it they just flood
the room so over time you know you've
got all these fungal infections on your
skin and so over time you just accept
that they're gonna crawl on you I woke
up you know constantly with them
tickling me going on my face on my mouth
you kind of in in the end you rebelling
against it and you're going days and
days without sleep and they had to put
me on some medication but you learn to
be at peace with your cell mates whether
they are humans are insects in the long
run otherwise you're going to do
yourself in psychologically so I learned
all of the characteristics if you start
like slapping a sandal down on while it
releases the chemical smell and these
warrior ones come running under your
cell door
if they manage to lay their eggs which
are in that piece of a worm it looks
like a piece of a worm and they'll
attach that under your bunk or they'll
attach that to one of your books if you
don't notice it and that thing bursts up
and all those little ones come out they
are all over the place as well then some
prisoners were doing cockroach races
gambling on the winner if you try and
drown them they just pretend that
they're drowned and they pull they get
into this position but they're actually
holding oxygen to themselves they're
just crafty little bastards
I saw white ones look like albino ones
but yeah I mean I just watch her in the
end and just just laugh at them and I
would cement the toothpaste cement
all the cracks in the walls I remember
one time I submitted my whole cell I was
so proud of myself this is the smell
smell minty fresh we got this sheriff
joe arpaio gave us this toothpaste
called a mirror fresh and years later it
was low he's buying from China or
something the years later there was like
it was learned that was like antifreeze
in it and all this kind of [ __ ] yeah so
that night that I sealed the whole cell
up and I was at peace the guards come
roll up at words we're moving you
through another cell I didn't have any I
didn't have any toothpaste left and that
Sal was just even worse with the
cockroaches from the cell bird left you
know I tried to meditate at night sat in
my black and white striped trousers
pants
I took them into my pink shorts sit on
some books get in the position and I've
got my trousers tucked into my socks so
that they can't you know start crawling
up my legs I'm just just a few inches
away from the wall and they're all over
the wall behind me but when you were
asleep when you're trying to sleep on
that bunk the bunk is like inches away
from the wall so you just they're right
in front of your face all night long so
I was in that maximum-security facility
for another year after my first
she spent the whole second year twenty
and two months a year and two months in
the maximum security Madison Street jail
which was not you know a completely
cockroach infested so I had to learn to
harmonize with the insects
[Laughter]